Well,
how are you, Entre Mejía greets you with your
brief informative today, Wednesday, June 9,
the sentence continues today for the
man who killed five cyclists
north of Searchlight last December.
The driver your importan would face
up to 40 years in prison. He admitted that he
was  under the influence of
methamphetamine and pleaded guilty to
two counts of death resulting in
family members of the five victims
asked the judge to give him the
maximum sentence of 40 years behind
bars
while a mother accused of
killing her  son and abandon body
near mount spring is in
custody yesterday i know from morenos
rodriguez was arrested in denver after
a nationwide search authorities
believe the minor was only seven years old
well you were still alive in las
vegas' on may 27  he and his mom
stayed in a hotel the night
before the body was discovered on the
side of the state highway
authorities are still investigating  hey what was the
possible reason
changing the subject thousands of families
are close to losing their homes and for
this reason clark county wants to
help a forum is scheduled this
morning inside the serveis community center
near spring and safe various
organizations as forced to be  of
southern nevada will talk about the
possibilities of avoiding an eviction
these organizations ask the
community to understand their rights
related to housing and how they
can obtain financial assistance
now the weather conditions
we will have another very windy day
temperatures reaching 90 degrees
For today, however, the alert
for strong winds will continue for the rest of the
day and then tomorrow, a
spring Thursday in the 80s, the temperatures
will rise warmer as we approach the
weekend. Have a nice day, I am
Héctor Mejía and this was your brief
information on  Kirchner in Spanish